welcome to this video yeah you very much
liked the recent videos that are
produced on my own over the board games
and I'm going to do more those this is
about a game that I played about three
weeks ago with the classical longtime
control in the in the German league the
third leak where my team plays and my
opponent was a veteran international
master Jurgen Fleck was rated 2390
around the game that was played so
pretty evenly matched encounter yeah
something about the preparation for the
game because you always think your head
what what what what are you going to
play
I recognize that and we can go to hear
that Fleck
he is playing mostly mostly two openings
against the d4 Nydia 3c for complex so
Nani for openings now he mostly plays
two things he plays the King's Indian
and the Slav in recent years I was
seeing that he was preparing the Slav
more and I was focused on that when I
was looking at his games I saw that he
preferred to to play play sharp systems
for example what he what he has played I
had played a number of times was the
board Winnick Sammy Slav very sharp
opening which is maybe slightly dodgy
but also very very tricky for white to
prepare if you have no basic knowledge
and I don't have any really basic
knowledge my normal response to the Slav
at the moment this is to play Queen b3
or Queen c2 one of those moves however I
had a preparation problem with that I
only recently had played this and in a
game just a couple of month ago which is
in the database and I knew that my
opponent is is preparing very thoroughly
before the games and looks at recent
games and so
and in fact this turned out to be the
case after the game he said he had
something prepared against this so what
I wanted to do is I wanted to to play
something that he did not expect but
what on the other hand is safe so
nothing that is very very demanding from
a theoretical point of view to prepare
at the end I came up with and I hope
you're not falling asleep with the
exchange sloth this opening I had played
and tournament chess before but the last
time was nine years ago
so it was nothing that he prepared and
it turns out to be that this is all
right it is very often the case that
black players they think that with the
with the exchange white is only playing
for were drawn and yeah not not it's not
very ambitious however that's not the
case I didn't want to play a draw in
this game I just wanted to to play a
play it safe and try to pose some little
problems and see what he's doing about
it
and let's see what happens I played
Bishop f4 this is the first little
important thing it's important to play
this move first here if white wants to
play the exchange Slav he really should
start with exactly this move the reason
is that if you put it on f3 the knight
iam you limit yourself very much in your
setups we will see this later in the
game it's a bit difficult to understand
right here but you it will get more
clear I get clearer when we come to
later positions
also white can play Knight c3 here of
course but this has a slight drawback
that quite funny enough it's not used
very often the black plays here black
has the funny apply e5 leading to
interesting play or he has the reply
knight c6 which after Bishop f4 can
allow this there are some funny side
lines that black can play so they're not
necessarily brilliant but Bishop f4 is
the cleanest way to avoid that
black plate Knight f6 93 96 the only
real the only way to try to exploit this
Ernie Bishop move is Queen b6 by the way
after which white is normally
sacrificing the b2 pawn which is quite
sharp so it's not not really a dull
opening all of the time however he
didn't play that black as usually played
we played 96 developing which is of
course a good news now III enter we note
that I'm still delaying the development
of the bishop and the night I'm sorry
the reason is if we look at further
black now plays a6 this is a normal line
nowadays like is addressing the knight
b5 idea with 97 coming and what he also
does is he plays a somewhat useful
waiting move if white now plays Knight
f3 black is able to play Bishop g4 and
this already is a position that white
has no hope for an advantage anymore the
reason is that after the moves like this
should be - black is just training off
this and plays Bishop d6 Natan and with
the knife not coming to e5 it's very
difficult for Y to do anything in this
type of very symmetrical position in
fact the bishops are not as useful
especially here the f3 Bishop is it's
quite useless if we compare this the
Knights can be more effective in this
position for example black might go for
a nice tour like that so I avoided
Knight f3 this is a very typical almost
mistake it really gives up any hope to
play for an edge so this was what I had
in my preparation and I was thinking how
can I pose some problems here Bishop d3
is the main move here the idea is that
after Bishop
for now why complain it2 at least with
this after a bishop trade the the bishop
is not misplaced on f3 or white can play
f3 those kind of ideas I had a look at
that but I I didn't like it very much
and then I found that white can do
something else
what can also play the somewhat somewhat
strange move Bishop be true and this is
what I played at the end in the game
there should be two is quite interesting
it has more than one idea the main idea
is that it can irritate black a little
bit because in response to the normal
looking most Bishop f5 which he played
after some minutes like that white also
has the additional possibility to go g4
this are also looked at in my
preparation but I did not really like it
that much it also weakens White's
position quite a bit it can lead to very
unclear play something like this happen
in a game between under 18 and one how
they unfortunately made the draw very
soon afterwards but as you see this is a
pretty yeah pretty well position my idea
was different I had anticipated Bishop
f5 of course and I just played Knight f3
yeah note that now I can go to her three
because Bishop g4 yeah he has not be
sure he doesn't have Bishop g4 anymore I
mean he could play it here but it's just
the loss of a temple um yeah what is the
point of this the point is that here
black is some post with a with a with a
question what to do next
the problem is that the very natural
means is six is probably it's probably
not imprecise but it makes life a little
bit more difficult for black and this
was the point that I wanted to to check
what is he playing now it seems that the
the most precise move here is rook c8
why rook c8 is useful anyway because
this is the
half-opened file and the point is if I
go Queen b3 now which is pretty typical
attacking this this weakness on b7 he
has tonight a5
the reason is or the the big point is
that now if I give the check black can
just play b5 if I now go for a sacrifice
he can block this easily because the
bishop here is still protected yeah this
is very important
rook c8 instead of e-cigs in the game he
played a6 we go back to the game 6 1 I
went Queen b3 and now we we see there is
a difference with the movie 6 being
played now Knight a5 is not good
there is Queen a4 check and after b5 I
can just sacrifice this piece because
now this is a absolutely deadly pin
yeah e 6 is breaking off this diagonal
so there is a big difference between
east 6 and rook c8 and he played a 6 and
I think this is not really a mistake but
it makes live as mentioned a bit more
difficult after ecigs
Queen d3 as mentioned was played now
Knight a5 the normal response is not
possible so what should he do it turns
out that the move rook is 7 which is
what he played is not not very not very
satisfactory it seems that after Luke a7
Black has a hard time to equalize really
um 7th was played however black still
has a good move here and this is Bishop
to d6 and yeah this is something that is
not so easy to play if you don't know it
it's hard to figure out over the board
the point is you just ignore b7 hanging
if I'm taking this have now there is
Knight a5 and my queen is trapped funny
yeah white can theoretically speaking
look at this it's not totally crazy
you're giving up the Queen for full rook
piece and pawn but it is ultimately I
guess not sufficient if we look at if
you look at this castles 94 White has
some compensation yeah the king is in
the middle and he had White has a good
structure but it shouldn't be enough to
compensate of course I don't need to
take on b7 and give up my queen like
that the real test of this is of course
the caption takes and then Queen b7 now
I'm just winning in the pawn
however after castles the situation is
not clears black a threatening rook b8
winning the Queen so white can retreat
and after let's say this is not the only
move Knight before Black has a very
decent compensation for the pawn they
have been one or two games played
earlier that that came to that came to
this in fact there was one one game that
was played just a couple of days before
my game I wasn't aware of that of course
played between two Spanish players in
the nura's yeah and I am an defeated
master facing off here they they played
it with castles knights e2 rupee one
rupee eight Queen a form of c8 black
definitely has compensation for the
point it is easy once you see hm but
it's not so easy to do over the board
when you're faced with those decisions
should I really sacrifice upon that
early
he went with as mentioned Luke a seven
it does not look so terrible because
very often you do that this rook a7
maneuver to BB 7 because it's quite
often the case that the White Queen is
not so ideally placed here as well and
then you can just move the rook back
once the Queen has retreated but here
after the immediate Knight e5 there is a
problem black really now has nothing
better than to trade off on e5
takes and now he went 97 around here you
can look at various other setups but
ultimately we will always come to to the
same situation it is pretty much
impossible now I think for black to
still completely equalize the game in
the next couple of moves an alternative
to 97 was some b5 the immediate b5 after
that I'm going to Castle which should be
7 and now a 4 this is a main problem
with the B point
what is is going to play a 4 after which
before it's pretty much forced if black
takes yeah the the the combined pressure
on the aether will be too much you will
lose the podium so before Knight back to
b1 castles 92 and this is the same
structure that is appearing in the game
in fact if black plays 97 here we would
would transpose this is however little
bit more precise for black I think still
not a very entertaining position to play
but it seems to be a little bit a little
bit tougher for me to to make to make
headway 97 was a bit accommodating I
think I went back to g3 keeping the the
bishop of course and now B should be 7
yeah B 5 years is a similar similar
situation there are some interesting
lines though if we look at b5 here let's
say I'm castling normal Knight f6 back
yeah it's it's a little bit strange yeah
but just I want to show one idea that is
in the position 92 and 94 a5 it's quite
interesting what can even give up an
exchange here for 4 interesting play it
shows that even from those kind of dull
dull openings or opening through the DAR
reputation you can get get sharp
positions something like that it's
definitely not
definitely not not boring White's a
point is exceptionally strong it's not a
forced nine it just shows that there are
some interesting ways to play on the
Queen satyam really based on the fact
that blacks position is not totally
harmonious yeah he went Bishop e7 which
i think is quite logical in connection
to 97 castles castles
rook FC one of course the F rook goes to
C 1 naught the a rock because I want to
have the a rock on a one for possible
waveforms yeah and here it is very very
difficult for black to to defend this
position he he went with b5 obviously
knowing I mean we had a look at the game
afterwards obviously knowing that this
is immensely weakening lots of squares
and pawns on the Queen side but it's
very difficult for black to play this
position there are some direct ways to
lose the game for example a normal move
like twin b6 and it looks totally normal
but it is in fact losing right away
because of Queen 95 that b5 is very
strong a piece sacrifice out of the blue
yeah but the point is this is threatened
winning the Queen and then Knight is
attacking the rook so black has to take
Bishop c7 Queen a6 Bishop b5 and white
wins the Queen oops
yeah it can happen really quickly even
in those kind of lame openings Knight d5
isn't quite nice response to Queen b6
yeah and what happens if he is not
playing b5 let's say he plays awaiting
news you create then night a4 is the
idea white is threatening Bishop c7 and
this is very very problematic now if
black now plays b5 I'm going to go to c5
and it will be very very difficult to
tolerate this night you probably have to
take it but after the capture white is
getting a super strong C pawn note that
this is supported by the bishop and the
rook so this is really quite a lot and I
have a four to make it even more
problematic this is almost winning for
white I think very difficult to black
yeah so what should he do b5 not
possible a tricky reply is Queen a5
which might gets some counter play with
Queen d2 or possibly Queen B for
exchanging the Queen however White has a
good move here Bishop f1 this is a good
prophylactic move it prevents any Queen
d2 with tempo and really asked like okay
what are you going to do next if black
is doing something yeah let's say where
h5 is really sitting looking and let's
say h6 um nothing move then again this
is a this is a good reply yeah aiming
for domination on the Queen side
something like like this for example
it's a super agony for black I'm just
invading with all pieces and probably
will win material quickly him a very
very difficult position already okay he
went b5 and b5 and yeah now I think the
next step is clear I need to make sure
that the Queen side is opening up a four
okay no choice black has to push before
taking on a4 is basically giving up the
a pawn so he has to push this and I'm
going back to be one yeah why to be one
because d2 is a good square which has
multiple ideas I will from d2 I have the
idea to go to f3 to e5 this happened in
the game or sometimes Knight d2 to b3
can also be an idea because C 5 and a 5
might be good squares as well so it's
really not a problem that the knight is
back on b1 for the moment yeah here he
played 9 f6 which is quite normal but it
also shows that the earlier Knight d7
move was probably not that great
he was I think thinking about Queen b6
which as we saw did not work out when he
played 97 yeah Knight f6 was played
during the game I was briefly thinking
maybe black should do
something very ugly and just heck this
night off to play this position it is
not fun really not but the night coming
to e5 is also a huge problem later I'm
not sure why it is quite substantially
better now in any case it's only it's
difficult to really am yeah to judge
what is the right around what is the
relatively best defense yeah he didn't
take but he took on if he didn't take he
played 9 f6 intending 94 yeah ok of
course I go 92 that's pretty clear and
yeah like now played the move Queen to
d7 and maybe Queen a 8 was a tougher
defense intending rook c8 another way
white keeps an advantage um with the
move a5 him very important move that
makes sure that the the rook is always
tied to this defense of the a6 pawn
white is still enjoying a very nice
position here maybe it was a bit tougher
then then the game continuation but it's
already quite difficult to give black
some advice he played Queen d7 I went
Knight f3 yeah very logical a5 was also
strong yeah this move as mentioned on
crenate this was an idea on 27 it also
is but I really wanted to get the knight
- to e5 quickly this seemed it seemed
very logical to me that's 95 96
this whole Queen side operation has
weakened lots of squares
especially c6 is weakened after the beep
horn has pushed to before they plan to
played rook c8 and I went 925 and here
may be Queen d1 was was also possible it
is as mentioned not it's not totally
clear what the best move
but what is always keeping an edge yeah
he played Queenie eight queen bee 7s
maybe a bit tougher just a little bit
tougher after that I'm not quite sure
probably f3 is a is a good reply yeah
which makes sure that there's no nightie
for coming it keeps more pieces on the
board and makes mi position a little bit
more a little bit more flexible I can
sometimes put the bishop he ever wanted
taking this or like he can keep the keep
the bishop which is the most important
thing also I still have the a5 idea for
instance after Luke a 8 a 5 is still
giving white a good position yeah he
went he went to e8 after which I played
Queen d1 yeah Queen t1 is a is a good
move the queen is not doing much anymore
on b3 and it has more than one idea the
main idea is to control it c1 so that
I'm actually just intending to take on
c8 and then play Luke c1 again to occupy
the file there are some additional idea
sometimes even Queen f1 is an idea to I
say six pawn but first and foremost it's
about the C file yeah he played rook a
to a8 yeah you really you really have
problems here I was thinking this is
also move Bishop d6 but after that White
has a very strong reply in fact if we
look at this I can take and now White
has a super strong move knight c6 that's
very nice
yeah I'm attacking the rook and yeah
like really has to take it the knight
then Luke c1 is strong the point is that
black cannot really recapture him as
rook c8 will win the Queen so white has
gained the total bishop pair and
dominance on the C file this is
fantastic for wider almost almost
winning
so there are some some funny for some
funny tactics even yeah he went rook 88
not this move but 88 and now I can play
it simple I just took on c8 and now
black of course cannot recapture with
the rook as just a six thoughts like had
to take with the Queen instead yeah and
now it's simple I just take the C file
Queen B 7 and Knight to c6 finally yeah
the knight is arriving on this fantastic
square he played Bishop to f8 yeah
understandable it's not like this Bishop
is so great but hmm if it plays
something like that for example I can
amongst other things
just take and play rook c7 which is
which is very great yeah for me
I'm dominating here Queen c1 on the C
file a5 is weak and I can even push the
the knight back if I want it's just
fantastic
so Bishop f8 is also what I am what I
had expected
umm yeah here I played 95 Queen b6 here
I actually missed something
umm I think before that I'm I'm pretty
positive that I played almost yeah I
played best moves or close to best moves
here I can play better really bishop c7s
m' is better then what I played the idea
is that it's pretty straight forward
yeah black plays Queen eight seven and
then rook c6 is strong I saw that but I
wasn't totally sure how how strong it is
also the move that I played this is also
quite good it both as an advantage this
is probably even even a little bit more
than that I was a bit unsure if maybe
I'm
somehow not coordinating my pieces right
here but white is just much much better
here in this position um probably this
is as much even better than what I
played I played the very
attractive-looking move rook c6 it's
quite funny a black if black takes the
knight this Bishop c7 trapping the Queen
in fact that is what he did of course he
saw that the queen is lost but he was
really desperate at that at this moment
what black should do is play Queen d8
yeah ignore the knight then I'm going to
continue with something like this f3
again keeping this square under control
so that 94 is not coming 98 97 Queen d7
rugby six something like that white is
playing for this invasion on the Queen
side and still has an excellent game and
and big advantage but the other
continuation with Bishop c7 immediately
was was a bit stronger however in
practical terms this was very successful
this rooks e6 move because after this he
really took on a5 and before you say huh
he's an IME shouldn't blunder his Queen
the thing is he saw that but he felt
like passive defenses useless and he
wanted to just change the position
somehow to to sort of get an imbalance
even if it's not not good for him I
understand this decision really you
don't want to suffer in a passive
position all the time he was pretty much
frustrated about this cause of the game
anyway
yeah takes on a5 Bishop c7 the queen is
stripped and he has rook c8 of course
this is the point after this and this my
bishop is slightly offside and this is a
reason why black actually could have
some hope here the problem is that there
is a very concrete reason why this is
not working in turn this is the move g4
not the only move but it's it's a good
move it gains a tempo in a way on this
Bishop and make sure that I have
some additional space for the king so
that I'm not back ranked me to do
anything this is a danger for what his
back rank is a bit weak this is however
very clean when the reason is that after
Bishop move we can also go to g6 it's
not a huge difference I always have
Queen e1 and this is important it looks
at this pawn and this is the key thing
I either win the pawn or after b3 it was
just what he did in the game I can play
Bishop before and this makes sure that
my offside bishop is getting into play
this way also when this bishops are
traded I get to activate my queen and
this happened in the game he played 94
I took them Queen before check and here
white is really totally winning the pawn
on a6 is also lost
he tried Knight to d6 and the 936 is
allowing a nice finish to the game and
he resigned after the next move the move
for white to finish this off immediately
is we should be five hands nice not
difficult but but still nice just
attacking the rook and well he resigned
but after captures captures the rook is
attacked and if it moves somewhere else
then b6 I'll just take the six was
checked and win with the b-pawn after
rook here I go Queen c5 and we see that
the queen is totally dominating here
with the pin and the tech here white
will win and win the house here
something like like this is going to
happen and the rook is lost so yeah a
nice game I was pretty I'm pretty
satisfied thinking that I really made
little mistakes or inaccurate moves it
shows that the the exchange variation
here are in the Slav it has it has a
drop of poison it's not always drawing
weapon in the hands of a player that is
some is prepared and has some ideas it
it can pose some problem too
two black if you play an opening like
the slaw for sometimes it can also apply
to some extent to an opening like the
French defense where the exchange
variation has a very draws and our
reputation yeah you shouldn't always
think that your opponent is is just
playing for a draw if you plays one of
those somewhat dull lines sometimes they
just want to play a play a bit safe and
try to press from a position of total
security and this was basically my
attitude in this game I didn't want to
play a draw quickly or something I just
wanted to to have a safe game and try to
yeah just it's just like asking your
opponent are you are you really
completely playing this perfectly in the
first couple of moves or are you not and
he made some little inaccurate
inaccurate moves like this rook is seven
probably and yeah maybe be five there
are some some not so accurate moves and
all of a sudden black was in big trouble
so it's it's not like though some those
Dan openings always lead to a draw
yeah and for the white player I can
really recommend to if you play d4 and
you face the Slav it makes some sense to
have the exchange variation of the Slav
in your repertoire it can be a super
safe choice and can always be played
regardless of the situation it's not so
great to play if you really need to win
super super badly but if you just want
to play for win with a sort of if you
want draw and hand then it's it's a
pretty pretty decent choice yeah I hope
you enjoyed this game and I'll cover a
new game of mine right served
tomorrow so if watch watch out for that
this this will have a little bit more
technical action by the way thanks for
watching